hello girl hi my name is Stanley I'm
Taylor I'm Devon and today we're gonna
have physical therapist to review our
posture my back has always hurt
growing up it never feels good it always
feels like it's hunched a little bit or
slouched I'm always had bad posture and
it's kind of affected how people view me
and even self-confidence and whatnot I
pride myself on having good posture I
think it all stems from being a
competitive horseback rider for like 15
years I still sometimes get complimented
for having good posture
hopefully my posture is still good
posture has always kind of been a
concern of mine I just noticed that I
hunched a lot and it's something I've
always wanted to correct but haven't
known how to so I'm really hoping to get
a lot from this and finally have the
posture that I feel like I should be
having on a regular basis my back hurts
and I wanted to not hurt so please
please help please okay the first person
is Devon now what we see do with Devon
she looks like a real pleasant young
lady she's got a little bit of rounding
of the upper back do you see that Brandi
show yourself heads forward now the type
isn't bad she's got the upper arm
vertical which is what you want but the
lower arm is going slanted up a little
bit the monitor itself needs to be
raised up because she's looking down
that's what's causing that up around me
right so the big thing is if she gets a
separate wireless keyboard and then
raises the screen quite a bit higher
puts a keyboard down on her lap and
she's good she's gonna be good they are
right about my back being rounded that's
always been a concern but looks like to
have a higher screen and lower keyboard
thanks Bob and Brad you're the best next
victim is Taylor seems like a nice guy
has a nice beard we start off I seen him
walking and the things that Brad I
noticed right away is again the slight
rounding of the upper bag but what else
do you see Brad his shoulders slightly
go in yeah there was wrong there also
wounded this way end and what's
interesting is he walks out he goes but
and he gives his shoulders a little bit
squeeze back like this he's trying to
inherently get it back into the right
position so we'll look at his sitting
now again he's got kind of the slight
rounded up her back
but again the shoulders are rounded
forward to some of this occurs because
the screens are just too long but his
keyboards high - I mean up his keyboards
high to him his arms don't even touch
his arm rests and that's why those
armrests are there so you can rest and
relax your shoulders but it's too high
and it doesn't allow that again he needs
to work on stretching his pectoralis
major and minor to stop that rounded out
shoulder halleluja stretch that we do
yep and then chin tucks in order to
bring the chin back if there's one
universal thing to say about everybody
who is on these videos you gotta raise
your screens they're just too long so
their biggest complaints were definitely
my shoulder rounding forward and along
with everybody at my screen being too
low they say I have to do a lot of arm
back stretches like that they gave me a
lot to work with and I know I want to
rearrange my desk for them thank you Bob
and Brad okay next person is Stanley he
talks about how bad posture has affected
his life and it's affected his
confidence he's young he's able to
correct it it's not so bad he we can we
can work with this yeah so Stanley the
first thing we're looking at your seated
posture add your workstation your screen
is just way too low
the other thing is is every 20 minutes
there are some simple stretches that we
have on video as well that he should be
doing take a break from the screen and
take 20 seconds to a minute and just do
some postural stretches and go back to
work he says my screens too low I don't
know I guess I feel like put books under
this and I really thought about it I'd
see how that makes sense I guess I'm
kind of like hunched down to look at it
from here thanks Bob and Brad all right
we have one more to review she's got
pretty good posture she's probably got
the best posture of anybody would watch
today the other thing when she stands
sideways just a little bit of a sway
back very bad yeah yeah we're gonna show
you here we're gonna exaggerate she's
leaning on her ligaments here it's not
bad now but over time it could get worse
and she could start causing her to to
actually round out a little bit or up
her back we're talking over years she
has really good sitting posture you see
how she how straight she is Brad yeah
she has a slight rounding in the upper
back yeah see that their head just kind
of going
but if she would do some chin tucks yeah
it would really make her see her ears
just slightly in front of her shoulder
we would like to have it over the
shoulder itself if you sit well it
carries over to into your standing there
walks right she's got really good
posture with walking what did you say
about her Brad it looks like she had you
know she's walking like she's in a
beauty pageant and going across the
stage very nice there she was Miss
America do they still have that if I
don't know if they still have that well
Bob okay I can't believe you haven't
been watching and keeping up with it she
shares a laugher yeah hop giggling but
she's got a good fairly good back
support
now look her upper arm is his vertical
like it should be the lower arm do you
see that there is a slight slant
downward right what we want her screen
is higher than most people right and
she's got the separate keyboard so she's
not looking down as much it could be a
hair high yeah she could put a couple of
books under there that aren't you yeah
Congrats Merle that's your probably the
best one over though before we looked at
she's got the best posture I'm feeling
pretty good these two dudes just
freaking blew up my ego like past where
it ever needed to be they said my arms
looked good
which like didn't even know that came
into playing with posture thank you so
much Bob and Brad you just made my whole
entire day
you